113 questions about evolution
with john perry evolutionary question
number 16
what is lamarcian evolution
hello ladies and gentlemen john perry
here today
i am going to cheat during my uh you
know
113 questions about evolution by
reading a little mini article
from darren nash's book evolution in
minutes this is
i've talked about this book before here
in like one of my book review videos
this is probably my most used
book on evolution you know most books
i'll read once
um and then and actually you know
by the point that you're teaching
evolution you're teaching a topic of any
kind
every time you read a book on that topic
most of what you're reading you've
already read before
it's actually becomes really tedious to
read books
on your topic of interest because it's
it's all repetitive
but the cool thing about this book is
it's just it's got like
i don't know 100 little articles in it
and they're all super short articles
they really only give you just enough to
get a taste
of the issue that you know that darren
is is writing about
but because we have the internet now you
can read one of these articles
and then do a deep dive online lamarck
and lamarckian evolution
the theory of evolution by way of
natural selection describes
how the outcome of genetic variation is
shaped by selection
several other models of evolution have
been proposed though
among the most persistent of which is
lamarcian
evolution john baptist lamarck argued
that
change in organisms was driven by
deliberate choice
that they modified their habits by will
or effort
and that their biology and anatomy
changed in step with
these decisions so they willed their own
evolution
into existence you can hear a lot of
people talking about that today
different uh variations of that today if
you go on like someone like the the
woo-woo spots on youtube um
people will be talking about how you can
will yourself to
evolve and change and okay i might be
over emphasizing will
here so what happens is that the
environment
changes animals strive to survive in
that new environment and so they do a
bunch of behaviors over and over and
over again
they will themselves to do these
behaviors over and over and over again
but it is that repeating of a particular
behavior
that lamarck thought would end up
exaggerating that trait in
this organism's offspring might be a
little bit wrong to say that they will
themselves to evolve it's that they
behave repetitively and that causes them
to evolve
in lamarck's view it's still fairly
popular
as an idea there are some arguments made
today that cross-generational epigenetic
inheritance might be
considered a form of lamarckian
evolution but uh
maybe i'll talk about that here in a
minute let me just finish the
the article here here's a popular
example of how this might work
if in every generation giraffes crane
their necks upwards in a continual
effort to reach ever higher
so their necks lamarck proposed would
gradually
increase in length today we know that
this concept of evolution is erroneous
giraffes did not grow long necks because
they stretched a lot
but because natural selection favored
the survival of individuals with longer
necks
that arose through genetic variation
lamarckian evolution was surprisingly
popular until the middle of the 20th
century
especially in france i mean that the guy
is french so
kind of makes sense that his stuff would
be popular in france
yeah lamarckian evolution is you know it
was a precursor to darwinian evolution
i believe lamarck had published yes yes
lamar had definitely published before
darwin did so
the idea of common descent that all
organisms share a common ancestor
that was actually a somewhat common
idea before darwin and so lamarck and
other people were talking about this
and it's actually you know you can go
back and find even ancient texts
where people are talking about the idea
that humans are
just another type of animal and that
were related in some way to the other
animals
so there's a misconception that you know
the idea of common ancestry was
discovered by darwin
that's not the case the the idea had
actually been around for quite a long
time before darwin
what darwin did is he just discovered
this process of descent with
modification
acted upon by natural selection is what
gives rise to adaptations and
you know before he had proposed this
lamarck was proposing
that you know we we will our adaptations
into existence
or by doing a particular behavior
repetitively we
cause uh our own evolution to happen
down a certain line the data
does not support that idea there is
as i mentioned earlier this idea that
heritable epigenetic changes so these
are changes not in
actual gene sequence but in the way that
genes are
bundled within a chromosome and the way
that a gene is bundled
ends up determining how often it gets
used by the organism
that has it bundled in that particular
way
so there's there have been claims that
uh changes in how dna is bundled
that can be passed on from parent to
child that those
are could be considered a style of
lamarckian evolution
it's it's something that i really i i'd
like to address that without
actually having a guest on that that
makes that claim
because it's really it's something that
i just don't i don't see the point
of making those sorts of statements the
way that dna is bundled is temporary
it's not permanent in order to get
permanent evolutionary change you need
to have changes in the actual nucleotide
sequence
and epigenetics doesn't do that so
uh i mean there's a way that you can
kind of you know
muddy the waters by saying well now that
the gene is bundled in this new weird
way well that means that the selection
pressures on all the other genes have
changed because now this gene is going
to be for at least several generations
it's going to be behaving differently
than it would otherwise so you could say
that
that is causing genetic changes
to occur um
so anyway it does get a little bit
complicated
and muddy most people are like no
i mean let's talk about epigenetic
changes and how they affect
evolution but let's not try and rebrand
evolution because
of the fact that epigenetic changes can
occur
so and i i agree right now i mean i'm
pretty solidly on that ladder group i
don't think we need to rebrand
the field of biology because we
discovered that uh you know
genes can be packaged differently
sometimes it would be interesting to
have someone on that is a researcher in
this field and that
is really strongly trying to make that
case so that we could get you know
some more opinions than just my own on
this matter
and and darren's darren of course worded
things fairly strongly in his article
here
lamarckian evolution is a thing of the
past that's
lamarkian evolution in a nutshell the
rejected theory of evolution that is
still somehow
constantly popping up again as time goes
on
so next question